anyway here with reaction former CIA
station Chief Fox News contributor Dan
Hoffman and Florida Congressman Mike
Waltz Congressman your take
um I'm concerned that NBC probably gave
into some pressure from the Biden
Administration sounds to me like they
might have been right
Sean of course we want every American
home but appeasing dictatorships
appeasing terrorists are never in the
interest of the United States and the
whole reason Sean that Putin the Iranian
regime the syrians the Taliban the North
Koreans continue to take American after
American hostage is eventually they hold
on to him long enough they dig in enough
we cave and we give them a better deal
how about this how about we don't let
Putin dictate the terms you're the White
House Press Secretary saying well here
was the choice the Russians gave us how
about we dictate the terms how about
every terrorist group every dictatorship
out there in the world knows they touch
a hair on an American's head and the
costs are going to be so high so painful
economically diplomatically even
militarily that they don't tear dare
touch another American but what he has
done tonight maybe a tactical win today
but it's going to result in more and
more and more Americans being taken
hostage down the line
because they know at the end of the day
there's only upside for them there's no
downside uh whether it's Putin the
Iranian regime you name it uh and it and
it's just my heart breaks for the wheel
and family my heart breaks for Americans
being held around the world and my heart
breaks for future Americans that are
going to get snatched off the street the
next time a dictatorship wants something
so Dan Hoffman you got The Merchant of
death Victor boot one of the world's
most notorious armed arms dealers
and you get Brittany Greiner whose only
charged with well she was charged with a
drug violation a minor one she got nine
years in prison uh but then you have a
marine who'd been held by the Russians
since 2018
um why didn't he hold out for both
before giving up The Merchant of death
it seems like a horrible deal for the
U.S even though I am very glad that that
Brittany Greiner is home I I had said
many times that I hope we get her out of
there
yeah I think we can have both of those
uh make both those conclusions tonight
Sean we can be thankful that Brittany
Greiner is home but at the same time be
critical of a deal this was uh certainly
a deal that Vladimir Putin will look at
as a major public relations Victory
Victor boot wasn't just The Merchant of
death he also served in the Soviet Army
and Vladimir Putin is going to portray
this as getting his guy home going
toe-to-toe with Russia's main enemy the
United States and bringing his guy back
home while at the same time our uh
former military officer Paul Whalen
Maureen is still languishing in a
Russian prison and I'm really concerned
about his health you know you've got
rampant covet there he probably hasn't
been given any vaccines vaccine
resistant tuberculosis and all the other
things that you got to face in a penal
colony where he's living a grave concern
about about his future and look it's
awfully hard I don't want to disparage
the negotiators I'm sure they tried
their best Vladimir Putin's not doing
too well at fighting Wars but he's doing
pretty well at uh at negotiating and
outwitting us I think and getting more
than he deserved he got way more than he
deserved I think certainly we should
have gotten both of them if we're going
to give up this guy
um we'll see what happens in the future
are our prayers are with him as he's
still in prison in the gulag up there